It makes you think that like,
it seems crazy now,
but it really won't be crazy.
I think a generation from now for another country to threaten at least sanctions
and maybe military action to deal with that.
You know,
after World War II,
we built a whole liberal international order around the principle of human
rights.
That would have been unthinkable in the 20th and yet it led to a series of
military invent interventions over the next century,
half century because people were behaving badly toward their own citizens.
If we could do that,
it doesn't seem all that crazy to me that say 30 years from now,
uh,
unempowered imperial China looking at someone like Boston,
Ireland,
Brazil would just be like,
no,
you can't do that.
I'm just going to,
we're just going to go in and like take you out.
And this is what I mean when I say it's a kind of all encompassing,
all impacting threat.
Our politics will be shaped by it are geopolitics will be shaped by it.
Our,
you know,
our,
everything will be shaped by it.
We could have climate wars like in the not too distant future.
Jesus Christ.
How is this being received?
The book?
Yeah.
Are People,
people resisting him?
Is there any anybody that wants to debate you on this?
So I,
you know,
I wrote this article a couple of years ago that produced,
I mean it was a huge sort of viral phenomenon,
but it produced also some scientific criticism and um,
you know,
we published a fully annotated version where every single night we showed where
every single line came from,
but there were still scientists who were arguing about whether the messaging was
precisely calibrated,
whether it was too bleak to dark.
Um,
the book has had none of that.
I mean it's first of all,
it's been to best at first week it was on the times bestseller list number six,
it's bestseller in England.
It's been in that of the Amazon top 10.
Um,
and all of the reviews have been really kind.
I think this goes to what you were saying before.
I think like the conversation is changing.
People are actually really interested in
talking seriously about just how big a deal this is in a way that they might not
have been just a year ago.
Where is the resistance though?
Is there any resistance to it right now to the bus?
Well,
not just the book,
but just the concept in general.
73% of Americans believe climate change is real.
70% of Americans are concerned about it.
Those numbers are up 15% since 2015.
Who are the 27 that don't,
I mean,
I think it's,
you know,
it's a hard right wingers.
Yeah.
But you know,
those numbers are,
we live in,
we live in a culture now where like most people's worldview passes through a
prism of partisan politics.
So like,
you know,
there's amazing studies that show that in the night in the early nineties,
there was no partisan divide between,
uh,
on the,
on the question of whether Oj Simpson was guilty when you control for race,
Republicans and Democrats had the same idea about Oj Simpson's guilt.
That is totally unthinkable today.
And there's now a huge partisan split on whether 12 years a slave deserves an
Oscar.
Partisanship has totally taken over our,
our minds such that the fact that we have 73% of Americans believe global
warming is real and happening.
To me,
that's a really fucking high number actually,
because one of the two parts,
I don't think that the Republican party is really anymore a denier party.
I think they're just a party of skeptics and self interest.
They want to like look out for business interests,
which actually the calculus there is changing.
Wish I could talk about in a second.
Um,
but people don't want to believe that horrifying things are real because who
would,
it's terrifying.
Um,
but 73% of the country,
that's a lot.
I mean that's,
you know,
that's more support than there is for just about anything.
Um,
so I'm like basically,
and the speed at which that,
those numbers have grown is really dramatic.
I said 15 points since 2015 eight points just since March has moved up.
That's incredible.
Um,
and I do think that the economic logic is really powerful here.
So it used to be the case that there was economic,
conventional wisdom.
That action on climate was going to be really expensive because you were
required massive upfront investment and it would mean also foregoing economic
growth.
But all of the new research the last couple of years reverses that logic.
Totally.
So there was a big report 2018 that said that we could add $26 trillion to the
global economy through rapid decarbonization by just 2030.
We could avoid all of these horrible $600 trillion impacts that we're talking
about if we decarbonized rapidly.
And there are also obviously business opportunities there,
their whole solar empires to build their whole new electric grid to build.
Um,
so the economic conventional wisdom is now that fast action on climate is better
for the economy,
then slow action on climate that hasn't yet totally taken over the perspective
of our policymakers globally.
But I think it will soon.
And when it does,
I think that we'll see like a real sea change in,
in their,
um,
perspective.
Because I think for a long time,
even people who cared about climate thought,
well I want to do something,
but if I have to like cost some people,
some jobs and costs like a percentage point of economic growth,
that's not worth it.
Let me just kick the can down the road.
This is a slow moving phenomenon.
We'll invent our way out of it.
We'll grow our way out of it.
But all of the new research says like,
let's get started right now and
we'll see how that plays out.
I mean,
if we really have to have global emissions by 2030,
it means really,
really aggressive action,
which I don't think is possible.
But I do think that we'll see much more aggressive action in the decade ahead
than we've had in the decades in the past.
So you think that once there's a financial incentive for people to,
uh,
either,
some sort of an industry that reduces carbon or something along those lines,
industries that are working to mitigate global warming,
that once there there's a financial sort of a benefit for these people to it to
innovate and to,
to move forward with this,
that that's what we're going to see.
Real change.
Yeah.
Well also that,
um,
I mean direct investment of particular companies,
but also,
you know,
government leaders who around and say if the economic picture is going to be
better 10 years from now,
if we make massive investments in green energy than it would be an,
and even like pass laws,
you know,
regulating safety,
fuel efficiency,
or even banning internal combustion engines,
which I think will happen within a couple of decades.
Um,
if that's going to be at the economic picture,
taking that path is much rosier than the economic picture of inaction.
I think they'll go down the path of action.
Um,
and you know,
again,
the question is how aggressively,
how quickly,
um,
and in what form.
But I do think that,
you know,
I do think the incentives will be different five years from now than they looked
five years ago.
And that'll be,
that'll be huge.
So that,
that you think would be a great motivator for people to shift their perceptions
and particularly right wing folks maybe amongst the 27% that are in denial?
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
if you look around the world,
denial is not really a problem anywhere,
but the u s there's a little bit of an in the UK,
but it's a totally American phenomenon.
And when you understand that the u s is only 15% of all global emissions,
cause that's just typical American arrogance.
Like what,
what do,
what do you think is the root of that?
Uh,
I think it's,
it's basically bad behavior by the oil companies.
I mean,
they've like put out really aggressive,
um,
disinformation in denial.
You ever see the movie a merchants of doubt?
Yeah,
yeah.
Perfect example of that,
right?
Yeah,
totally.
Um,
yeah,
and I know that the people who wrote the book too,
who are really,
really great,
um,
and you know,
it's especially horrifying because in the sixties and seventies that the oil
companies were like doing some of the most ambitious research on climate.
So they are,
you know,
then they ended up suppressing that going forward.
But they knew shit about how the planet was going to change before any of the
rest of us.
Really.
Um,
yeah,
there's no alternatives back then and there was no real emission standards.
So it's like this a,
that's when catalytic converters started being enacted.
Well,
you know,
somewhere around then if we had started decarbonization in 2000,
which just coincidentally was the year that Al Gore won the popular vote for
president,
um,
we would have had to globally cut emissions by about 3% per year to get below
two degrees.
We're now at a spot where we have to cut them by about 10% per year.
And if we wait another decade,
we're going to have to cut them by 30% per year,
which is like an unthinkable of great.
So we wouldn't have had to take such aggressive action if we had started early,
we would have had to just be doing moderate kind of on the margins,
um,
changes.
But we're now in a situation where the problem is way too big for that.
And there are people who want to talk about the solutions that could have been
useful 20 years ago.
Now I'm talking about the carbon tax is like one quite popular thing to talk
about.
Um,
the UN says that in order to be effective,
the carbon,
a global carbon tax would need to be perhaps as high as $5,500 a ton.
And there's nowhere else in the world.
There's nowhere in the world where there's a tax that's even one 100th as high
as that right now.
Um,
and the places in the world where they do have carbon taxes,
everybody's admissions are still grew up going up.
So there,
there was a time when like the kind of like you don't have to change anything.
We'll just like fiddle on the margins here could worked if we had taken,
if we had really been focused on it.
But we're sort of past that point now,
unfortunately.
Um,
but it's interesting,
you know,
the,
the talking about the oil companies,
um,
I think they,
you know,
I think they're responsible for denial,
but I also think that denial is not all that important in American politics.
Um,
because when you look around the world,
you see many countries,
which v with very different politics,
even quite universally focused on climate issues who are not behaving any better
when it comes to carbon than we are.
And so you think,
well,
what is the sickness here?
Is that the Republican Party and their climate denial or is it the fact that all
of us just want,
you know,
more better,
cheaper stuff and we have a really hard time conceiving of different paths that
don't push us forward towards more consumption and you know,
more,
um,
more than modern amenities that we sort of assume we'll keep accumulating over
time.
I mean,
people say financial capitalism is the problem.
I have some sympathy for that view,
but I also look around the world.
I see social democracies who are behaving really poorly when it comes to carbon.
I see socialist countries who are behaving really poorly when it comes to
carbon.
Um,
it seems on some level like it's even deeper than the systems that we have to
organize and manage.
Um,
our cultural priorities.
And there are now,
you know,
getting back to the village,
any of the oil companies,
they're now all these lawsuits that are being brought against them for basically
on the model of the,
of the cigarette company is like that for climate damages.
And um,
that may be,
they may be victorious.
They may put some of these companies out of business.
Um,
I think it's not that likely,
but it's possible.
There are also other lawsuits that are happening in a really interesting,
there's one in the Netherlands that some people held,
um,
the Dutch government.
They basically,
the Dutch government was not honoring the Paris accords and citizens sued to
hold them to that and we won the case.
So the Dutch government is now obligated legally to do better on climate than
they were doing on their own.
And in the u s there's this amazing court case called Juliana versus the United
States,
which is a lawsuit being brought by kids using this kind of ingenious use of the
equal protection clause.
They're arguing that their generation has been exposed to climate damages,
that there the previous generation,
their parents generation were protected from.
And so they're saying this climate policy is a violation of the equal protection
clause.
You're not protecting us in the same way that you protected our parents.
That's at the District Court in Oregon,
which is just one level below the supreme court.
I think it will win in the District Court almost certainly won't win in the
Supreme Court,
but if it did one of the Supreme Court,
it would immediately obligate the u s to a totally maximalist climate policy
because it's literally impossible to protect the next generation from climate
damages as fully as the previous generation was.
But they'd be to do everything they could,
which would mean sort of suddenly something like the um,
the World War Two scale mobilization that the UN calls for,
which would be really kind of dramatic and incredible.
And I think that's one path forward is through litigation because so many places
in the world,
it's not just politics are a nerd,
like American politics are a nerd.
It's just there's a lot of slow moving bureaucracy and,
um,
slow moving public opinion.
And in the same way that a lot of civil rights victories were fought and won in
the courts,
I think we might be able to make some progress in,
in the courts on climate too.
We'll see.